do you need a little pick-me-up a boost
for you to feel better well it turns out
there are little things that you can do
throughout the day to improve your
health without spending a ton of time in
fact just five minutes i'll be sharing
these tips and tricks all season long in
a segment we're kicking off right now
and it's called good in five
[Applause]
all right now today we're gonna tackle
posture this is something we do all day
long and we don't think about it um but
posture is the key
to so many health benefits and bad
posture honestly leads to just
so much
negative physical effects posture alone
is such a powerful powerful thing
so we pulled our audience to find out
whether or not you all think you have
good posture and here's what you said 66
percent of you um
think you don't have good posture if you
said that raise your hand
okay i'm definitely with you and 34 of
you think you did raise your hands well
teachers pets
all right well for those of you who need
a little posture perk up first up is
something to get to help you feel better
all right and i want you all to check
out this little gadget it's an upright
go posture trainer it's a device that
you wear on your back that gives you a
gentle vibration
to remind you to fix your posture and
sends a result to an app in your phone
and it senses your slouch through
something called bio feedback three of
our audience members are wearing one
okay guys hi how are you hi drew
all right um what is this like what does
it feel like it's definitely a bit
jolting when you get the shock i'm just
not used to having it up here you know
like
how intense is it like on a scale of one
to ten i'll go with four
okay yeah i have a feeling i feel like
his it's a little bit more i guess maybe
i'm just gonna say
seven
yeah seven four
four
oh
well maybe women can deal with pain a
little i guess so
um but we can't do it without you so we
love you um all right the app has been
tracking your slouching let's see the
results
molly has had good posture 89 of the
time
not bad ryan has had good posture 94 of
the time that's because you've been
getting your butt kicked
and nicole says she has it says that you
have good posture 96 of the time
gosh
if that thing came on my back and my
phone come up it'd be like girl
you're a hot mess
okay next someone to follow i want to
feel better and i want you to check out
alex wong's stretches on tiktok alex is
known for his time on the hit show so
you think you can dance and he posts
videos of dancing and silly stretches
that just make you smile
and of course they're good for you and i
don't expect you maybe to stretch like
that holy cow
oh wow i was not looking at that
okay yeah yeah do it like alex wong does
it
so it's a good reminder that some basic
simple stretching can loosen up your
tension in your back and help you with
your posture and finally something to do
because i like action joining us is the
fitness expert who has helped me with my
physical health and wellness for oh god
15 something years it's marny alton
[Applause]
okay why is posture so important to our
overall health you're the expert
it's it's wild because it does so much
more we just think about it making us
taller and we occasionally hear like
more confident but it actually affects
your digestion um your circulation which
is like heart health and blood pressure
but also like glowy skin it gives you
energy when you're feeling kind of
lethargic um but i think like one of the
most exciting parts is it actually can
alter your mood like from your nervous
system perspective so when things are
feeling heavy
just changing your posture like going
from like a tense turtle think more like
i don't like a cartoon matador then
there's kind of space for joy to come in
there you go there we go wow i happen to
be wearing the perfect skirt for this
and like one of the things that we do a
lot right with the phone we're
we're constantly rounded looking at it
and then jutting our chins forward
towards it so one of the simplest things
that we can do since we're always on
these suckers really any device you can
do this with a computer as well but for
a phone all you got to do really simply
is bring it up to eye height and that's
going to just even without worrying
about all the other bits is going to
lift you taller it'll also draw your
shoulders back so you kind of think
about like um if you have your shoulder
blades are being pushed down into your
jean pockets like in the back of your
jeans and so here you can still text
right if you have a little pop that's
even better a little ring but you can
text like this you can look at things
like this you can scroll and then if
that arm but the important part is
getting all of those faces tall
tucked in and then tight so you're
supported all right well i love this
because this is something actionable
that can improve our posture thank you
so much marnie i love you
[Applause]
[Music]